THE CHAIR IS RUNNING A FEW
MINUTES LATE AND ABSENT A FULL
QUORUM WILL START IT'S A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
LET ME START OFF WITH SOME EARLY
REMARKS.
THE TRIBAL STATE --
GAMING COMPACT BEFORE US TODAY
IS ONE WHICH WAS EXECUTED ON
AUGUST FIRST TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN BETWEEN GOVERNOR BROWN.
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE LOVELY A BAND
OF LOUISIANA.
LOU AS NO.
INDIANS TODAY WE WILL HEAR FROM
THE PRINCIPAL ARCHITECTS OF THIS
CONTACT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND THE CHAIRMAN OF THE TRIED.
THE CONTACT AUTHORIZES THE TRIED
TO OPERATE A MAXIMUM OF TWO
THOUSAND SLOT MACHINES AT NO
MORE THAN THREE GAMING
FACILITIES. ONE OF WHICH HAS A
PRIMARY PURPOSE OTHER THAN
GAMING AND OPERATES NO MORE THAN
ONE HUNDRED SLOT MACHINES.
THE TRIBE HAS AGREED TO PAY THE
STATE IS PRO RATA SHARE OF COSTS.
THE STATE INCURS FOR THE
PERFORMANCE OF ITS DUTIES UNDER
THE CONTACT AS WELL AS A 6% OF
ITS NETS WIN CNET WINDS.
FROM THE OPERATION OF SLOT
MACHINES IN EXCESS OF THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY SLOT MACHINES TO
BE SHARED WITH TRIBES.
THAT ARE NOT GAMING OR THAT
OTHERWISE ARE NOT SUSTAINABLE
[inaudible]
CSUS.
SUBSTANTIALLY BENEFITING FROM
GAMING UNDER THE TERMS OF THE
CONTACT.
FROM ITS PAYMENTS TO THE REVENUE
SHARING TRUST FUND OR THE TRIBAL
NATION GRANT FUND.
THE TRIED MAY TAKE ANNUAL
CREDITS OF UP 270% FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS.
THAT IN PART BENEFIT COUNTY
RESIDENTS.
ALL COUNTY OF RESIDENCE FIRE LAW.
ENFORCEMENT PUBLIC TRANSIT
EDUCATION TOURISM AND OTHER.
SERVICES INCLUDING INVESTMENT IN
RENEWABLE ENERGY AND
CONSERVATION PROJECTS.
ONCE EFFECTIVE THIS COMPACT WILL
BE IN FULL FORCE AND EFFECT FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS FOLLOWING THE
EFFECTIVE DATE.
I'D JUST LIKE TO REMIND ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES THAT NO
FORMAL VOTE WILL BE TAKEN TODAY.
TODAY'S HEARING IS FOR THIS
COMMITTEE TO BE BRIEFED ON THE
CONTENTS OF THE CONTACT AS IT
CANNOT BE AMENDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
AS PETE ONE ZERO FIVE ONE BY
CENTER DODD WHICH IS PENDING ON
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR IS THE
RATIFICATION BILL FOR THIS
CONTACT.
AND AT SOME POINT WILL BE TAKEN
UP FOR CONSIDERATION BY THE
ENTIRE BODY ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR.
I WOULD LIKE UP PERSONALLY AND
AS A COMMITTEE THANK OUR
WITNESSES IN ADVANCE FOR TAKING
TIME OUT OF THEIR BUSY SCHEDULES
TO BE WITH US TODAY.
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO LET'S BEGIN
THE HEARING.
WHO WOULD LIKE BUT I'D LIKE TO
INVITE THE?
THE UP MEMBERS OF THE TRIBAL
COUNCIL TO COME UP IN
[inaudible]
PRESENT.
MR DOING WHICH YOU PROBABLY LIKE
TO SET THE STAGE FOR THIS
ACTUALLY.
THANK YOU AND I WILL --
GO LET YOU KIND OF HANDLE THE
INTRODUCTION OF OF THE DIFFERENT
PARTIES AND HAVE THEM READ --
ABSOLUTE CHAIRMAN MY OF MY HONOR
TO DO SO --
I THINK IS ALWAYS YOU PROVIDED
OUTSTANDING SUMMARY OF THE
COMPACT --
THAT THE BAND HAS THE NINETEEN
NINETY NINE TRAVEL STATE GAMING
COMPACT BUT CURRENTLY DOESN'T
HAVE ANY CLASS THREE GAMING --
THEY'RE LOCATED IN A BEAUTIFUL
SECTION OF NORTH SAN DIEGO
COUNTY BUT CLEARLY THAT PROVIDES
CHALLENGES WITH A GUIDE TO
DEVELOPING --
COMMERCIAL GAMING OPERATIONS I
THINK THEY THEY BEEN A DOING A
VARIETY OF THINGS INCLUDING I
THINK ZIP LINE TO TO TRY --
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
BEAUTIFUL LOCATION THAT THEY
HAVE BUT WITH THAT WITH THIS
COMPACT --
IT'S SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO
THE OTHER COMPACTS THAT WE'VE
NEGOTIATED YOU'VE RATIFIED I
THINK THERE A COUPLE THINGS
THAT'LL TOUCH UPON THAT ARE
UNIQUE TO TO LOW HIGH IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE [inaudible] ONE
WITH REGARD --
TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION
PROVISIONS WE'VE BEEN
NEGOTIATING WITH THE HIGHEST
PART OF A LARGER GROUP FOR THREE
AND A HALF TO FOUR YEARS AS WE
GOT CLOSE TO THE END OF THE
SESSION --
WE FOCUSED ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF THE TRIBE BEEN AND WERE ABLE
TO TO COME TO A FINAL AGREEMENT.
BUT THE ENVIRONMENTAL PROVISIONS
THERE ARE NEW AND THEY REFLECT
THAT -- THE
RECOGNITION THAT THAT --
THAT THE CHALLENGES FACING
SMALLER TRIBES OR A DIFFERENT SO.
WE BUILT IN TO THAT COMPAQ.
THE SAME BASIC --
STEPS THEY'RE INVOLVED IN IN ALL
COMPACT AT THE GARDEN FOR A
MIDDLE MITIGATION THE TRIBE WILL
IF THERE'S A PROJECT WILL
IDENTIFIED THAT --
OFF RESERVATION IMPACTS COME UP
WITH A PLAN TO ADDRESS THOSE
IMPACTS TO MITIGATION --
WHICH ULTIMATELY RESULTED IN
MITIGATION AGREEMENT IN THIS
CASE BETWEEN THE STATE THERE ARE
SOME --
STEPS IN THE PROCESS THAT
INCLUDE NOTICE TO OF ALL INCHES
PARTIES INCLUDING THE LOCAL
AFFECTED JURISDICTION.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE IS
SOME DISAGREEMENT AS TO WHETHER
THAT MEDICATION AGREEMENT
EFFECTIVELY MITIGATES THERE'S A
PROCESS FOR ARBITRATION --
IN ADDITION ONE OTHER UNIQUE
ASPECT ABOUT THE COMPACT
REFLECTS SOMETHING UNIQUE ABOUT
THAT THE TRIBE IN THAT IS THE
FACT THAT.
THEIR RESERVATION AND THE VERY
MIDDLE OF THE RESERVATION IS IS
A SPANISH LAND GRANT WHICH IS --
REFLECTED I GUESS ON THE MAP
THAT'S ADDED APPENDIX A OF THE
COMPACT AS AS A PORTION OF OF OF
LAND THAT --
IS POTENTIALLY ELIGIBLE FOR
GAMING UNDER FEDERAL LAW --
BUT IF IT BECOMES --
ENTRUSTS HELD IN TRUST BY UNITED
STATES FOR THE TRIBE THAT
WITHOUT AN AMENDMENT TO THE
CONTACT THE TRIBE COULD GAME ON
THAT LAND --
SO THOSE ARE THE TWO THINGS I
THINK BETTER.
OF DIFFERENT ABOUT THE COMPACT
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
OTHERWISE ALTERNATE OVER TO THE
CHAIRMAN OF RODRIGUEZ AND FROM
THE LIVE BAND.
WHEN WE GO AHEAD OF CHAIRMAN
RODRIGUEZ AND AND?
FELLOW COUNCIL MEMBERS IS. TO
MAKE THEIR PRESENTATION GOD
THANK YOU OF ORDER THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN DINNER ALL YOUR STUFF
GOING SHERMAN EVERYBODY FOR
BEING HERE ARE JUST A PART
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT --
DOES TROUBLE CHAIRMAN FOR THEIR
LAWYER VANDER CLOSE IT'S THE
SAME YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TIME JUST
SLIPPED ON OUTLOOK THAT OKAY.
BY I DO THE SAME THING.
OF THOSE.
I X. FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND OUR
TRIBAL STATE COMPACT EVERYWHERE
A FEW WORDS ABOUT WHY WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE RIGHT
RATIFICATION OF THIS OP ART
HEALTH BACK.
OUR TRIBE DOES NOT HAVE
CURRENTLY OPERATING CLASS
[inaudible]
THREE AW [inaudible]
AUTO RETRIBUTION [inaudible]
THE TRIBE.
REYES AGREES OVER. EIGHT
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED ACRES.
ON THE SIDE OF PALMER MALL.
AND UPPER RANCHERS.
DOES SANTA FE RIVER AND ITS
HOMES OVER FIVE HUNDRED IF FIVE
HUNDRED ENROLLEES MEMBERS OUT OF
TO A TOTAL TRIBES MEMBERSHIP OR
SEVEN HUNDRED MEMBERS WE GOT.
ARE ARE TO BE TREATED ARE COULD.
COMMUNITY LACKS ADEQUATE HOUSING
INFANTS.
EVERITT STRUCTURES SUCH AS COMES
OF ROADS WATER ELECTRICITY AND
SEWER SYSTEMS.
I LOOK AT WATER AS A MAIN ISSUE
AND ARE.
IF IT STRUCTURE FOR DOING
BECAUSE OF GO FIRES UNDER OUR
RESERVATION OR OR ANY OTHER
PLACE.
IN OH SEVEN WE'VE GOT WORKED OUT
95% OF THE RESERVATION WAS
MURDERED [inaudible]
ON IT.
AND WE LOST. THIRTY SYMBOL ON IT
TO IS KINDA HARD COMING BACK
AGAIN I THANK ALL THE REST OF
THE LOCAL TRIBES.
ON THE OTHER.
GENEROSITY OF HELPING US OUT
HUNDRED AND SO IN RETURN LOT OF
THE STUFF THAT COMES ON WELL I
WOULD LOVE TO DO THE SAME THING
WHEN PEOPLE GET DOWN THERE.
AND AFTER YOU DON'T TRY TO HELP
PEOPLE TO DO THE SAME WAY TO YOU
AND TO ME THAT WOULD BE REALLY
GRATEFUL ON RIGHT THERE.
HOWEVER NEARLY OF VILLA.
OR YEARS.
OF HARD NUCLEATION DETROIT
BELIEVES THAT THE TRIBAL TO
SPEAK OUT OF OFFICE GAMING
COMPACTS SIGNED.
IT GOVERNOR BROWN LAST MONTH
PAYER AND WILL GIVE DETROIT
CHANCE TO START CLASS ST GAMINE
AND INCREASE TRIBAL SELF
GOVERNMENT AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT [inaudible] HUNDRED
WE HOPE TO GROW AND STRATEGY XIN
FROM THERE ARE REVENUE SHARING
TRUST FUNDS. TWO POINT WHERE
DIATRIBE WILL CONTRIBUTE REVENUE
SHARING DO TRUST FUNDS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WATER.
GREAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE ANY
COMMENTS.
OKAY.
YEAH THANK YOU --
YEAH I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY ALSO TO SPEAK.
AND THE CHAIRMAN HAS PRETTY MUCH
SAID IT ALL BUT AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE YOU GUYS.
AND YOUR SUPPORT IF THAT.
YOU KNOW BECAUSE OF THAT THIS IS
A BIG THING FOR THE TRIBE --
I GUESS THAT ONE OF OUR BIG OF
HURDLES WE HAVE CROSSES OUR
LOCATION --
THEY SAY THAT'S YOU KNOW SO
REALLY IT'S THREE THREE THINGS
LOCATION LOCATION LOCATION.
AND WE PUT A CASINO OR EVEN
BUSINESS SO --
WHERE LITTLE UP FAR OUT --
WE WERE ABOUT THREE THOUSAND
FOOT LEVEL UPON A MOUNTAIN SO.
WE HAVE TO GO UPGRADE.
AND BY BELOW US IS RINCON GA HAS
A BIG HARRIS CASINO DOWN BELOW
WHICH IS MAYBE ABOUT FIFTEEN
MINUTES FROM US.
BUT BECAUSE WERE UP THE HILL AND
BACK EAST A LITTLE EAST FOR THEM --
IT'S A CHALLENGE.
TO INVITE PEOPLE UP AND AND YOU
KNOW BECAUSE WHEN I GO UP THERE.
WHEN THEY HAVE A CASINO DOWN
BELOW RIGHT SO WE HAVE?
TO IT IT'S A CHALLENGE AND WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE A BIG CASINO WE
KNOW IT'S JUST ANOTHER STEPPING
STONE FOR US.
BUILDING I'M FOR STRUCTURE IN
AND IT'S ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE TO COME UP NAVY AND AND
YOU KNOW GIVE US A CHANCE TO
BUILD OUR INFRASTRUCTURE AND
HOMES AND FOR KIDS AND ELDERS.
I WOULD BE WE WOULD LIKE IT.
YOUR SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MISTER GRIFFIN I SEE THAT YOU'RE
HERE --
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS --
MY NAME'S JACK RIBBON.
I WORK WITH UNITE HERE THE HOTEL
AND CASINO WORKERS UNION IN THE
UNITED STATES AND CANADA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR LETTING
ME TESTIFY WE ARE.
REALLY HAPPY WITH HOW
[inaudible]
THIS --
SECRETARY OF OR OR LEGAL
REPRESENTATIVE --
FOR THE GOVERNOR AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE TRIBES
HAVE WORKED TOGETHER OVER THE
PAST NUMBER OF YEARS.
AND CREATING A SITUATION WHERE.
TRIBES HAVE AN ABILITY TO CREATE --
AND AN OPPORTUNITY --
TO TO EDUCATE THEIR KIDS AND MOM
AND CREATES AN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WHILE KEEPING IN
MIND THE OTHER AREAS THAT NEED
TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT WORKERS
LOCAL COMMUNITIES ETCETERA.
AND WE JUST.
SUPPORT THIS COMPACT.
IN EVERY WAY WE POSSIBLY CAN.
AND WE WHICH THE LAW HIGH UP
BAND OF LIVE SANYO INDIANS ARE
THE BEST OF LUCK --
AND HOPEFULLY YOU'RE UP AND
RUNNING SOON.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THOSE
COMMENTS.
HOW ABOUT OF --
WE OPENED UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
DOES ANYONEWISH TO STEP UP AND
AND GIVE.
COMMENTS OF SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WITH
COMMENTS OF OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK.
TO THE DIGEST ANYONE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
SEEING THAT I MIGHT HAVE A
COUPLE MISTER DOLAN IF YOU COULD
YOU KNOW THIS THIS COMPACT --
IT'S PRETTY MUCH A
STRAIGHTFORWARD MERE OF MANY OF
THE CONTACTS IT THAT EXISTS BUT
THIS ONE DOES HAVE A LITTLE
TWIST TO IT DOES ALLOW FOR THREE
FACILITIES.
COULD YOU EXPLAIN TO US HOW WE
WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ARE ON ON
THAT ACTION AND HELP EXPLAIN IT
BETTER TELL YOU SIR I I THINK
THAT.
THE NINETY NINE COMPACT ALLOWED --
FOR TO YEAH ANY NEGOTIATIONS
INVOLVES --
TRYING TO FIND --
TERMS THAT WORK FOR FOR BOTH
PARTIES AND AND I THINK FROM
THAT THE STATE'S PERSPECTIVE AS
LONG AS WE HAVE EFFECTIVE.
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT DO WE HAVE
THE PROVISIONS FOR THE GUARDIAN
VIABLE MITIGATION --
DEPENDING ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF OF IT TRIES RESERVATIONS SOME
TRIBES MAY --
SEEK TO A GAME AND TO FACILITIES
SAM THREE SOME HAVE AGREED TO
ONE JUST BECAUSE OF THE NATURE
OF THAT THE RESERVATION SO WE WE
WORKED HARD TO TRY TO GET.
AND WE'RE PLEASED THAT THAT --
I THINK IT WORKS FOR THE TRIBE
BUT IT ALSO WORKS FOR THE STATE
WITH REGARD TO THE PROVISIONS
THAT ARE CRITICAL TO US WHETHER
IT'S LABOR.
ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION THE
CREDITS THAT PROVIDE SUPPORT TO
KNOW IF THE TRIBE GROWS TO THAT
LEVEL OF SUPPORT NOT JUST FOR
THE MEMBERSHIP BUT ALSO FOR THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY.
WELL I I CERTAINLY AGREE I THINK
THE COMMENTS THAT MISTER
CHAIRMAN MADE --
KINDA REFLECTED WHAT THEIR GOALS
AND ASPIRATIONS ARE AND THEY
RECOGNIZE --
THE FACT THAT.
THEY'RE A SMALLER COMMUNITY AND
AND AND THEY RECOGNIZE THAT THEY
COMPETE IN THE BIGGER WORLD --
SO I WAS JUST CAN RAISE IN THE
QUESTION AND I WAS RAISING A A
CONCERN WITH WITH ANY STUDIES
DONE IN MARKET SHARE.
IF THAT'S SUSTAINABLE ON HOW
THAT COULD WORK AT JUST BECAUSE
OF THE CLOSE PROXIMITY OF
COMPETITION.
AND HAVING THREE WOULD THAT BE
SUSTAINABLE YEAH THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION --
VICE CHAIR I WOULD SAY THAT THAT
THE COMPACT ALLOWS THE TRIBE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO GROW THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE THREE OR THAT THEY'RE GOING.
TO GO TO TWO THOUSAND I THINK WE
ALL KNEW THAT THERE WOULD BE
CHALLENGES I THINK LIKE ANY.
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
AGREEMENT OF THERE ARE A VARIETY
OF CONSIDERATIONS THAT WE ALL
MAKE INCLUDING --
GOING BACK TO THE MEMBERS PLAIN
WHAT.
WAS THE PRODUCT OF FOUR YEARS OF
NEGOTIATION AND I THINK --
THE TRIBE AGREED TO THE TERMS
THAT WERE IMPORTANT TO US AND I
THINK THIS WAS IMPORTANT TO THE
LEADERSHIP AND THE MEMBERSHIP TO
GET SOMETHING TO SHOW THAT.
THAT WHAT THEY GAVE UP WAS WAS
WORTH WHAT THEY GOT.
WHEN I THINK THAT SOME THAT
THAT'S REALLY GOOD COUNSELOR DID
YOU?
ONE YES I JUST WANTED TO COMMENT
THAT -- FOR
THAT RECORD FOR THE RECORD JUDGE
JAMES KAWAHARA LEGAL COUNSEL FOR
INVITING WANNA OF YOUR LAST YEAH
THAT'S IT --
LEGAL COUNSEL FOR THE TRIBE --
TO GET YOUR QUESTION DIRECTLY --
THIS PROVIDES OPTIONS FOR THE
TRIBE --
OBVIOUSLY THE THEY WILL NOT.
WANT TO CANNIBALIZE OUR OWN
MARKETS SO IT'LL JUST GIVE THEM
OPTIONS GIVEN THE SIZE OF THE
RESERVATION.
AND THAT THEY HAVE --
ACCESS TO HIGHWAY SEVENTY SIX OF
TO ENTRY POINTS ON THE
RESERVATION SO THIS WAS JUST
GIVE OPTIONS THAT THERE'S NO
CRIME.
PLANT HAVE THREE FACILITIES YES.
WHILE I APPRECIATE THAT.
MR DON'T MAYBE YOU COULD ALSO
ADDRESS FOR THE COMMITTEE THE
THE PAYMENT PROVISION --
THAT'S WITH INSIDE THE BODY OF
FOR THE ARTIST YOU HAVE.
OR THE TNG F. ON FUNDS MAYBE
COULD HELP EXPLAIN THAT FOR
EVERYONE HOW'S IT GOING TO WORK.
BUT YES SIR SO --
CONSISTENT WITH THAT THE COMPACT
THAT WE DID --
LAST YEAR WHERE THAT --
THAT THE DEVICE LIMIT IS LOWER
THAN SOME OF THE ONES THAT WE'VE
DONE IT AND SPECIFICALLY DEALING
WITH TRIBES THAT IN THIS CASE
SIR RECIPIENTS OF THE REVENUE
SHARING TRUST FUND OR HAVE
SMALLER FACILITIES.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT UP TO TWELVE
HUNDRED SLOTS.
WE BELIEVE THE TRIBE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO RETAIN THAT THE FUNDS
THAT THAT GENERATE FROM THAT THE
GAMING FOR THAT THE PROGRAMS
THAT THEY NEED WHETHER IT'S THE
EDUCATION THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT FOR THEIR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WHATEVER IT IS THE
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT.
BELIEVES IS APPROPRIATE FOR
INVESTING IN.
IN THEIR OWN GOVERNMENTAL
PROGRAMS BEYOND THAT IF THEY GET
ABOVE TWELVE HUNDRED THEN --
THE THE TRIBE WOULD BE
CONTRIBUTING A PERCENTAGE OF ITS
REVENUE FROM.
WITH THE REDUCTION FOR THE THE
KINDS OF CREDITS THAT AGAIN THAT
WE YOU'VE SEEN IN THE AND OTHER
RECENT COMPACT ALONG THE LINES
OF THE THINGS THAT YOU DESCRIBE
SWEPT WHETHER IT'S FOR PAYMENTS --
TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
DISTRICTS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
FIRE OR INVESTMENTS IN IN --
ON RESERVATION ACTIVITIES
WHETHER IT'S WATER CONSERVATION
RENEWABLE ENERGY HERE OR OTHER
KINDS OF THINGS THAT WE THINK
ARE BENEFICIAL NOT JUST FOR THE
MEMBERSHIP BUT FOR THE OVERALL
COMMUNITY.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WOULD LIKE TO OFFER
AN OPPORTUNITY.
AREN'T.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS YOU'D
LIKE TO AD --
IF NOT I DON'T THINK I HAVE ANY
MORE QUESTIONS I KNOW COUPLE
MEMBERS CAME IN AFTER THE FACT
THAT THE OF ME ASKING IF WE WERE.
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS SEEM.
NINE IF YOU.
HAVE ANY OTHER COMMENTS THAT'S
FINE IF YOU DON'T SIR.
THAT'S QUITE UNDERSTANDABLE.
AND SOME DELYLAH GOOD EDUCATION
FOR OUR KIDS AUDIT TIGHTLY ON
THERE.
ARE [inaudible]
AND NO.
JOBS. FOR OUR DRUG PROBLEM
MEMBERS HONOR.
WE'VE OPENED HIS SHIP LINE THAT
THE LAST THREE YEARS AND IT'S
BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL WITH MOST
OF OUR TRIBAL MEMBERS WORKING
UNDER.
A SO IT'S DOING REALLY GOOD.
AND I GUESS IS WHAT I REQUEST AT
PEOPLE JOBS AND EDUCATION
PARTICULARS.
AND I CAN'T FORGET THE SENIORS
BECAUSE I'M A SENIOR MYSELF SO.
I GOT LOOK FOR MYSELF TO IN THAT
PART OF IT SO I THINK YOU.
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE MISS CHAIRMAN MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN. FOR BEING HEARING
COUNSELOR --
TO REPRESENT THE ENTIRE TRIED WE
WISH YOU ALL THE BEST ON THIS IS
IS JUST AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
AS YOU KNOW IT WILL BE BROUGHT
UP INTO A FOR THEIR DATE --
WHEN MR DOTS REALLY?
SO I THINK WE'VE GOT ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT WE NEED FROM
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
FOR ATTENDING THIS HEARING AND
MAKING YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU MISTER DILLON MISTER
GRIFFIN THANK YOU FOR BEING A
HERO THANK YOU ALL THE CLERK
[inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT --
HEARING --
THIS WILL BE FOR THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
ON THE DRY CREEK RANCHERIA BAND
OF POMONA INDIANS THE AMENDMENTS --
TO THE TRIBAL STATE GAMING
COMPACT BEFORE US TODAY IS ONE
WHICH IS EXECUTED ON AUGUST
FIRST AS WELL.
THE PREVIOUS ONE ON TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN BETWEEN GOVERNOR BROWN.
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND DRY CREEK
RANCHERIA BAND OF POMO.
INDIANS TODAY WILL HEAR FROM THE
PRINCIPAL ARCHITECTS OF THE
CONTACT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
AND THE TRIBAL --
CHAIRMAN.
THE A MINUTE CONTACT WITH DRY
CREEK MAKES TECHNICAL
CORRECTIONS TO THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN CONTACT BETWEEN THE
TRIED AND THE STATE TO CLARIFY.
AND MORE EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENT
THE PRIOR AGREEMENT.
I'D LIKE TO JUST REMIND ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES THAT NO
FORMAL VOTE WILL BE TAKEN TODAY
TODAY'S HEARING IS FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO BE BRIEFED ON THE
CONTENTS OF THE CONTACT.
AS IT CANNOT BE AMENDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AS BEAT AND FIFTY
ONE BY SENATOR DODD WHICH IS
PENDING ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR IS
THE RATIFICATION BILL FOR THIS
CONTACT.
AND AT SOME POINT WILL BE TAKEN
UP FOR CONSIDERATION BY THE
ENTIRE BODY ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR.
WOULD LIKE TO ONCE AGAIN THANK
OUR WITNESSES IN VAN IN ADVANCE
FOR TAKING TIME OUT OF THEIR
BUSY SCHEDULES TO BE WITH US
THIS MORNING [inaudible]
MISTER DILLON.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO START OFF WITH
THE LEAD BRIEFING ON THAT --
YES SIR --
AT THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
INTRODUCTION AND OVERVIEW --
ACTUALLY THIS WILL BE REALLY
BRIEF AT COMPAQ SIR YEAH.
THEY SEEM TO GET LONGER AND
LONGER THERE OVER A HUNDRED
PAGES AND OCCASIONALLY --
JUST LIKE WITH THAT LONG COMPLEX.
GO BACK AND AND THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE OF THAT.
AS WE WERE NEGOTIATING LAST YEAR
THE TRIBE CURRENTLY HAS A
COMPACT THAT WE NEGOTIATE THE
RATIFIED --
LAST YEAR IT'S BEEN IN EFFECT
SINCE JANUARY OF THIS YEAR OF
THE TRIBE EMBRACE THE PROVISIONS
OF THE TRIBAL LABOR RELATIONS
ORDINANCE AB BUT PASSED --
FOR A PROVISION THAT THAT THAT
ACCEPTED ENROLLED TRIBAL MEMBERS
FROM THAT THRESHOLD OF TWO FIFTY
WHICH WOULD KICK IN THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THAT ORDINANCE
IN OUT -- WE
THOUGHT THAT WAS VERY REASONABLE
AGREED TO THAT AND HAD LABOR
SUPPORT OUT WHEN WE DID THE
ACTUAL DOCUMENT THOSE SEVEN
WORDS WEREN'T INCLUDED WHEN WE
REALIZE THAT THIS YEAR WE WE
NEED TO FIX IT SO WE ARE FIXING
THAT PROVISION AND MAKING SOME
OTHER.
TECHNICAL CORRECTIONS THAT'S THE
ASCENTIAL UP PURPOSE OF THIS
DOCUMENT --
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT ANY OF THOSE OTHER --
CORRECTIONS THAT WERE MADE.
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH MINOR
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFICATION
AMENDMENTS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN ON YOUR WITH US
TODAY --
CHRIS WHICH MISTER RIGHT MISTER
CHAIRMAN WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO GOOD MORNING NOW MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE --
IT'S CHRIS RIGHT --
THE CHAIRMAN FOR DRY CREEK
RANCHERIA AS JOE STATED --
YOU GUYS RATIFIED OUR COMPACT
LAST YEAR THANK YOU.
AND THERE WERE SOME.
MINOR ALL CHANGES AND SO I'M
JUST HERE FOR THAT.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
I KNOW MISTER GRIFFIN IS HERE
WITH AND HAS A COUPLE COMMENTS.
MY THING IS TO WORK.
ARE YOU SURE --
I AGAIN JACK RIBBON WITH UNITE
HERE THE HOTEL CASINO WORKERS
UNIONIZED STATES AND CANADA --
ALTHOUGH WE WERE SHOCKED
[inaudible]
SHOCKED.
THE JOB DILLON HAD LEFT THOSE
SEVEN WORDS OUT OF THE COMPACT
LAST YEAR.
ESPECIALLY SINCE WE THOUGHT THAT
IT WAS FINE.
AND WE SHOULD WE A SUPPORT THE
COMPACT LAST YEAR.
WE SUPPORT THIS YEAR.
AND YOU KNOW WE SUPPORT JOE TWO
EVEN THOUGH WE'D LIKE TO GET A
HARD TIME DOWNEY [inaudible]
WELL.
HOPEFULLY MISTER GOING YOU DON'T
TAKE OFFENSE TO THOSE HARSH
PANTS THAT HE PRESENTED A I'M
SURE YEARS STRONG ENOUGH.
TO TAKEN WITH A GRAIN OF SALT
[inaudible]
WELL WHETHER.
I'M.
OPEN THE A THE FLOOR TO COMMENTS
FROM THE PUBLIC --
IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE FROM THE
PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE RALLY TO THE CALL
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
SCENE KNOW QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS I DON'T BELIEVE I HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS JUST A COMPLIMENT
FOR YOU.
TO TAKE THE MOMENT TO STEP BACK.
RE READ THIS AND MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S FAIR AND EQUITABLE TO ALL
PARTIES SO THANK YOU MISTER
DON'T FOR THAT MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR KINDNESS.
AND THANK YOU TO THE OTHER
ENTIRE TRIBAL COUNCIL FOR THEIR
UNDERSTANDING FOR THE SLIGHT
OVERSIGHT.
ANYWAY THIS WAS JUST AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING AND WE
WOULD --
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING A PART
OF THIS.
WE HAVE ONE MORE --
HEARING.
AND THIS WILL BE.
AGAIN AN AMENDMENT TO THE TRIBAL
STATE GAMING COMPACT.
THAT IS BEFORE US --
WHICH WAS EXECUTED AGAIN ON
AUGUST FIRST TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN BETWEEN GOVERNOR BROWN.
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CORD HOOK.
KARUK THANK YOU TRIED.
IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT THE
TRIBE IS THE SECOND LARGEST
TRIBE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WITH APPROXIMATELY THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED MEMBERS.
THIS IS TRIVIA INFORMATION THAT
EVERYBODY BEST REMEMBER.
TODAY WE WILL HEAR FROM THE
PRINCIPAL ARCHITECTS OF THIS
CONTACT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND THE CHAIR OF THE TRIED.
THE AMENDED CONTACT WITH THE
GROUP --
TRIED CONFORMS THE PROVISIONS OF
THE TWENTY FOURTEEN CONTACT.
WITH THE STATE REGARDING WORKERS
COMPENSATION. TO THOSE OF MORE
RECENT RATIFIED CONTACTS THE
TRIBE HAS RECENTLY OPENED AND IS
CURRENTLY OPERATING DE GAMING
FACILITY.
S. B..
TWENTY S. B. TEN FIFTY ONE BY
SENATOR DON WHICH IS PENDING ON
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR IS UP FOR
RATIFICATION IS A RATIFICATION
BILL FOR THIS CONTACT AND AT
SOME POINT WILL BE TAKEN UP. FOR
CONSIDERATION BY THE ENTIRE BODY
OF THE SIMPLY I WOULD LIKE TO
ONCE AGAIN THANK OUR WITNESSES
IN ADVANCE FOR TAKING TIME OUT
OF THEIR BUSY SCHEDULES. TO BE
WITH US TODAY AND RECOGNIZE THAT.
THERE IS NO ACTION TAKEN HERE
TODAY IT WILL BE JUST THAT ON
THE FLOOR [inaudible]
SO.
MR DON'T.
WOULD YOU LIKE THE LEADOFF YES
SIR THANK YOU VICE CHAIRMAN THAT
AS YOU'VE INDICATED THE TRIBE
HAS.
A COMPACT THAT WAS NEGOTIATED
RATIFY THE TWENTY THIRTEEN
BENEFIT SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN
SINCE THEN ONE OF THE PROVISIONS
THAT WE'VE INCLUDED IN OUR OUR
COMPACTS.
HOME ADDRESSES WORKERS
COMPENSATION BY GIVING THE TRIBE
AN OPTION THEY CAN ELECT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE STATE PROGRAM
OR THEY CAN --
OPERATED INDEPENDENT THE
COMPARABLE SYSTEM AND WE PROVIDE
DETAILS WITH REGARD TO THAT THE
COMPONENTS OF THAT COMPARABLE
SYSTEM --
THAT PURPOSE OF THIS AMENDMENT
IS JUST INCLUDE THE LANGUAGE
THAT WE THE SUCH INCLUDED AND I
THINK ALL OF OUR CONTACTS.
TWENTY FIFTEEN INTO THE CREW CON --
THAT'S ALL IT DOES I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT --
THE TRIBE IS YOU CAN'T IT HAS
RECENTLY OPENED --
THEIR THEIR GAMING FACILITY YEAH
I THINK THAT IT'S A BIG DEAL NOT
JUST FOR THAT FOR THE TRIBE I
THINK 30% OF THAT.
THE EMPLOYEES ARE TRIBAL MEMBERS --
BUT IT'S ALSO A BIG DEAL FOR THE
COMMUNITY --
YOU KNOW CLEARLY IT'S NOT A TO
SEE A LOT OF ECONOMIC INVESTMENT
AND I THINK HAVING THAT.
THE AND ENTERTAINMENT OPTIONS AS
WELL AS THE JOB OF THE THINGS
THAT --
GAMING FACILITY BRINGS IS A BIG
THING FOR A WAY WEAKENED
SISKIYOU COUNTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU EVER
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE TRIBE
YEAH GOOD MORNING MELANIE GAVE
US WITH THE TIME CRUZ COMPANY --
ON BEHALF OF KARUK AND CHAIRMAN
AND A VERY WHO UNFORTUNATELY HAD
TO LEAVE THE CAPITAL EARLY.
TRAVEL PURPOSES SO IF ME TODAY --
THIS IS THE FIRST AMENDMENT TO
OUR TRIBAL STATE COMPACT AND AS
YOU HAD EARLIER STATED WE ARE
THE SECOND LARGEST TRIED TO
CALIFORNIA WITH OVER. THIRTY
EIGHT HUNDRED MEMBERS LOCATED
NEAR THE OREGON BORDER IN
CALIFORNIA AND TO PROVIDE JOBS
THE RECENTLY OPENED THE GAMING
FACILITY.
AND I WAS OPEN IN APRIL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND HIGHS AND HAD AN
IMMEDIATE BOOST TO THE LOCAL
ECONOMY. FOR EXAMPLE WHEN WE
BEGAN HIRING EARLY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE HELD A JOB FAIR FOR
TWO HUNDRED JOBS AND EAT
[inaudible]
SHOWED UP.
I'M SIMILAR TO OTHER TRIBES ARE
TWENTY FOURTEEN COMPACT IS A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE ABOUT
OUR SOVEREIGNTY WITH
IMPLEMENTATION OF CERTAIN.
AYE PROTECTION STANDARDS --
AND PRESENTLY IT COSTS MORE FOR
US TO ENSURE A GAMING EMPLOYEE
THAT IT DOES FOR A MEMBER OF OUR
FIRE CARILLO.
AND SO WE'RE LOOKING TO AMEND
THE WORKERS BECAUSE AND THESE
HIGH INSURANCE COSTS ARE
UNRELATED TO THE JOB AND COST
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS WHICH
RESULT IN A LOSS OF FUNDS TO OUR
ESSENTIAL GOVERNMENT SERVICES.
AND OTHER GAMING TRIBES HAVE
ENCOUNTERED THE SAME ISSUE AND
AS A RESULT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
SINCE GIVEN IT RATIFIED SIMPLE
COMPACT AMENDMENTS THAT
PERMITTED TRIED TO OPERATE ITS
OWN WORKERS COMPENSATION.
SYSTEM IF IT COMPLIES WITH
STRINGENT SURE ITS REQUIREMENTS
AND PROVIDES A SYSTEM OF REDRESS
FOR WORKPLACE INJURIES.
SO THE FIRST AMENDMENT YOUR
TWENTY FOURTEEN COMPACT REFLECTS
THESE ALTERNATIVE REQUIREMENTS
AND WOULD ALLOW US TO ACHIEVE
PARITY WITH OTHER TYPES IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE OFFER OUR THANKS TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS AS WELL AS THE
AT YOUR COMMITTEES YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU DID VERY
GOOD JOB REPRESENTING THE
CHAIRMAN [inaudible]
MISTER GRIFFIN.
I YES MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS AGAIN JACK RIBBON WITH
UNITE HERE THE HOTEL AND CASINO
WORKERS UNION AND WE SUPPORT.
THE GA CAREW COMPAQ AS WE DID
SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WILL OPEN UP THE FLOOR TO
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF THIS --
MEASURE.
SCENE NINE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
AGAIN SEEN NINE QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
I JUST HAVE.
ONE TIME THIRTY SEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT HUNDRED ROUGHLY MEMBERS IN
THE IN THE TRIED THAT'S A HUGE
NUMBER.
HOW LARGE IS THE COMMUNITY THAT
IT SERVES IN THE GEOGRAPHIC AREA
WOULD YOU SAY [inaudible] ONE
YEAH WELL THAT IT'S ACTUALLY A
LARGE RESERVATION I'LL JUST
ACKERMAN ALL AS A SO THAT THE
GAMING FACILITIES LOCATED.
WITHIN THE CITY LIMITS OF A WEEK
AND THERE'S THERE'S HOUSING
RIGHT THERE IS RIGHT OFF OF I
FIVE IT'S NEXT TO SEE YOU COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS.
THAT THE MAIN TRIBAL
ADMINISTRATION BUILDING IS IN
ISN'T HAPPY CAMP WHICH IS
PROBABLY AN HOUR PLUS.
AWAY AND THEN THEY ALSO HAVE
LAND IN ORLEANS WHICH IS ANOTHER.
HOUR PLUS AWAY SO IT ISN'T JUST
THE SIZE OF THAT.
THE MEMBERSHIP OR THE SIZE OF
THE RESERVATION BUT THAT THE
FACT THAT IT IS SO.
DISTRIBUTED YEAH SO A LOT OF
CHALLENGES IN AND WHERE WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT THIS AMENDMENT IN
THE COMPACT THE GAMING FACILITY
HELPS THE GOVERNMENT ADDRESS.
THAT WAS THE PURPOSE OF THE
QUESTIONS JUST THE EXPANSIVENESS
OF THE AREA.
GEOGRAPHICALLY THAT YOU SERVED
AS HE HUMONGOUS AND SO THE
OPPORTUNITIES.
ARE TREMENDOUS SO
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR OPENING
AND UP MUCH SUCCESS --
TO YOU.
THINK SO WITH THAT THAT THIS
CONCLUDES OUR PUBLIC HEARING ON
ALL OF THE CONTACTS THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY STATED.
AND I APPRECIATE ALL THE MEMBERS
FOR BEING HERE AND ALL THE STAFF
SUPPORT.
OUR THANKS TO THE GOVERNOR AND
HIS STAFF FOR ALL OF YOUR
EXCELLENT WORK ONCE AGAIN MISTER
DILLON UNIT YOU SHINE.
SO WELL SO ANYWAY.
THIS IS IT EVERYONE HAS A RIGHT
TODAY [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
ANYWAY.
HEARING IS CLOSED